what is this edible anus chocolates
let's eat some of these what's the real
part of it
just the label or edible anus Red Dead
yeah search that edible anus I don't
fully understand this now go to the
about us let's read the world's first
chocolate anus first saw the light of
day in 2006 London artist Magnus Irvin
made a range of them a multi-colored
chocolate to present in an exhibition
how did he do it
initially Mr Irvin tried to cast his own
anus with messy and disastrous results
whilst explaining his failure to a
chance acquaintance at a bus stop he was
gratified to find that his fellow boost
passenger was willing to allow him to
cast her anus was she hot though yeah
holy dude I could eat that out
[Laughter]
I could lick that dude that's pretty
good yeah that's pretty funny